all right so let's talk about that on
the clay and buck show newly minted
after his disastrous Twitter
announcement 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Ron DeSantis was
on the clay and buck show and he wanted
to uh address the issue of Pardons and
he says no pardon is off the table up to
and including Donald Trump this is a
couple minutes long let's get into it a
lot of interesting stuff here abandon a
big part of being president is pardon
powers do you think the January 6
defendants deserve to have their cases
examined by a Republican president and
if Trump let's say gets charged with
Federal offenses and you are the
president of the United States would you
look at potentially pardoning Trump
himself based on the evidence that might
emerge of those charges
the doj and FBI have been weaponized we
see that we see it in a variety of
contexts some of which you mentioned
some of it is the FBI going after
parents going to school board meetings
some of it's how they treat a pro-life
demonstrator how they don't go after
people that are attacking pro-lifers and
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
do on day one I will have folks that
will get together and look at all these
cases who people are victims of
weaponization or political targeting and
we will be aggressive at issuing parted
now some of these some of these cases
some people may have a technical
violation of the law but if there are
three other people who did the same
thing but just in a context like BLM and
they don't get prosecuted at all that is
uneven application of justice and so
understand the framing here and then
he'll get to the Trump part the framing
here is
we need Law and Order
but we can't allow people of different
political Stripes one to be prosecuted
and the other not like if you go after a
January 6th Rider but not a BLM person
if they did the same thing they should
both be prosecuted I agree the thing is
they're pretending like there's many
examples of that when in reality there
are not we're going to find ways where
that did not happen and then we will use
the pardon power and I will do that at
the front end you know a lot of people
wait until the end of the administration
to issue pardons uh we're gonna find
examples where web government's been
weaponized against disfavored groups uh
and we will apply relief as appropriate
but it will be done on a case-by-case
basis because I think you've got to make
sure that um because there's a whole
bunch of cases that don't necessarily
get headlines but if people are being
treated just because they don't get on a
TV or something they're being treated
disfavorably they need to have a fair
hearing as well and that could be from a
grandma who got arrested and prosecuted
too much all the way up to potentially
try himself is that fair to say when you
analyze what the charges might have been
brought on a federal level
I would say any example of disfavored
treatment based on politics or
weaponization uh would would be included
in that review no matter how small or
how yeah so that that's up to and
including Trump think about the argument
and the case DeSantis is making he wants
to be president he wants to be chosen
over Donald Trump to be president
Trump incited an insurrectionist Riot on
January 6th and rather than coming out
and saying the Republican party needs to
go in a different direction I condemn
what Donald Trump did in citing his
followers on January 6 but instead he
says I'd consider pardoning him I'd
consider pardoning him now let's put
aside the political calculation the
political calculation I've told you
before is he want he being DeSantis
wants to find some path
to appeal to the people currently
supporting Trump so that they might vote
for him and his calculation is if I
condemn Trump's role in the riots and
the attempted coup I'm getting rid of
all the Maga the potential Maga support
So DeSantis has made the calculation
that he's not going to do that but let's
step back from the political this is a
very dangerous and irresponsible thing
for Rhonda Sanders to say he is
undermining the rule of law
and undermining the accountability of
public officials or excusing uh public
officials from accountability Trump is
facing multiple investigations including
for his role in citing the January 6
Riot his business dealings classified
information handling
pardoning Trump would send the message
that he's above the law and his actions
don't have consequences and it will only
embolden the extremist elements of the
base who participated in the riots or
who who supported them or thought that
they were a good thing DeSantis said he
would also consider pardoning rioters
writers himself saying well some of them
were it was a technical violation of the
law we call those violations of the law
and when you say well it was a technical
violation but it deserves a pardon
you're either saying they were Justified
actions or that they were trivial
actions and all that will do is
encourage more violence and encourage
the potential for another Insurrection
and it will also by the way just deepen
the polarization and the division in the
country DeSantis talks about oh I would
become a United or whatever he's saying
I will use pardon power to favor what he
sees as disfavored groups who were the
victims of political targeting it's the
same victim mentality again and again
and again and when the world sees this
they look at it and they say this United
States what are they doing over there
what are they doing and DeSantis is
echoing another mistake from American
history when President Gerald Ford
pardoned Richard Nixon after the
Watergate scandal that was a mistake
that eroded public trust in government
it weakened our moral Authority because
it said okay yeah Law and Order except
for some vague unification of the
country we're going to pardon Nixon I
think it was a mistake I think it is a
mistake to be talking already about
pardoning Donald Trump now in the
meantime Joe Biden was asked about
pardoning Trump he just laughed it off
[Applause]
all right
I know what Santa said that if he became
president he would pardon Trump where
are you on the idea of President
pardoning Trump
[Applause]
Biden laughs and waves it off and this
is absolutely the right and answer and
by the way I think this is better than
Biden even saying I will not pardon
Trump
because if Biden says I will not pardon
Trump that will be politicized Biden has
been handling this perfectly which is to
say any time he's asked
I am not getting involved in any of that
I'm just not getting involved and even
the question would you consider
pardoning Trump you say yes I would well
obviously he wouldn't say yes you say no
I wouldn't people say well what if the
evidence showed it was politically
walking away
laughing and waving it off is the right
answer Biden should have nothing to do
with the prosecution of trump and I love
that he is staying out of it when
there's a non-fiction book I just don't
have the time to read having a summary
of the book is really valuable several
different platforms out there will
summarize books I've tried them all
short form is by far the most impressive
one and it goes Way Beyond what other
platforms do our sponsor short form not
only will Summarize the book covering
all of the key ideas short form also
provides analysis and commentary that
contextualizes the book comparing it to
what other books say about the same
topic and you can read or listen to the
entire thing in one sitting for instance
the book dark money by Jane Mayer about
how wealthy Republicans are covertly
influencing American politics short form
clearly and concisely sums up the book's
most important takeaways but it also
gives you a ton of other crucial
background about lobbying libertarianism
and that helps you really understand how
does the book fit into the broader topic
of conservative money in politics that's
why I love short form short form has
every genre politics business Tech
biographies and my audience can try
short form totally free and get 25 off a
subscription at shortform.com Pacman the
link is down below